what's going on guys this is rob and i
have an idea
you guys always know the best video
started out that way i have an idea okay
here's the thing
a lot of people are talking about the
x-men and the marvel cinematic universe
right and they're talking about the idea
like the x-men will be brought in and
like doctor strange 2 or something like
that because it's dealing with the
multiverse and so on
the more i think about this
the more i'm not so sure that's the case
what if kang
introduced the x-men to the mcu all
right bear with me on this right so
here's the thing if we do see the x-men
before like their official full-on like
movie debut i honestly think it'll be
like a cameo or something like that in
doctor strange too something along those
lines i mean again the rumors have kind
of thrown out there that like professor
x and wolverine will have like a cameo
or a role in doctor strange too although
the role of professor x looks like it's
part of the illuminati in an alternate
reality and i don't really know how they
would justify the appearance of
wolverine and i don't really care so
long as we get to see hugh jackman
playing the character in some capacity
but let's say the actual plan here is to
introduce the x-men in like an actual
film now as i understand it kevin feige
actually wants the x-men to appear in a
series which i think is a probably a
better idea
but disney wants the x-men to appear in
a movie so there's a lot of back and
forth going on there i wouldn't be
surprised if they split the difference
and they actually end up giving us both
i mean the play that i had for the x-men
i made a video on that years ago the
plan that i had for the x-men is that
you actually do both while you do a show
for the individual characters like their
individual stories and then you do a
movie where they all basically end up
coming together and like fighting as a
cohesive team i mean a lot of people
might say well that would confuse people
right i mean we're literally doing like
a show on disney plus and then we're
doing a movie and they've got to somehow
consolidate the difference i mean i
guess but like the new spider-man movie
has characters whose plot threats
haven't been referenced in 14 years so
i'm pretty sure people could probably
watch a tv show and a movie and make
sense of it all but the important thing
here is that i think kang is the way
that that comes in and i think it
happens because of secret wars so
recently i was talking to josh over at
denim nerds where we had this podcast we
absolutely killed it in the most recent
episode i'll post a link to it down in
the description but we were talking
about the idea of sega wars and he asked
me that question he said when we get
secret wars in the marvel cinematic
universe because it's only a matter of
time until we do and the russo brothers
direct it like they wanted to are we
gonna see like 2015 secret wars by
jonathan hickman or are we gonna see
like the original 1984 secret wars by
jim shooter and my response was we'll
see the original secret wars but it'll
be secret wars in name only it'll
actually be something more akin to like
avengers forever or ultron forever or
something like that those of you guys
who don't know what that is avengers
forever was a landmark story when it
came out because i mean it dealt with
things like rick jones and the destiny
force none of that really matters what
does matter is that avengers forever
focus on the idea of uniting avengers
from different time periods right so
imagine for example that you saw that in
the mcu right you saw like avengers from
different eras all coming together so
instead of getting the original chris
hemsworth for you get like fat thor and
then he is on a team with like sam
wilson captain america and like robert
downey jr from like iron man 2 and like
mark ruffalo incredible hulk and like
doctor strange when he had just become
sorcerer supreme after being trained by
the ancient one right but it's not like
the characters as they exist now and for
good measure we could throw in peter
parker like spider-man when he was
wearing like the costume with the
goggles when he would like fashion that
suit for himself we could throw him in
as well right regardless it's different
characters from different time periods
my thought here was that we would
effectively get that but it would also
take the form of ultron forever now
ultron forever was a story that in some
ways i think was better because i
basically dealt with dr doom who was
actually a doombot uniting all these
avengers from different time periods to
defeat ultron who had literally
conquered everything at that point in
time like he literally killed odin took
the odin force and was now the all
father right like like ultron was crazy
powerful during that whole that whole
story arc but it was really really
really really cool for what it was and
so what this would mean is that king the
conqueror would not be a villain who
would be thrown away like thanos right
where like he does some stuff then they
kill him never to be seen or heard from
again that he would actually linger on
that if you look at what's going on in
the marvel cinematic universe one it
looks like disney and marvel are
actually learning from their mistakes
when it comes to like killing off all
the villains which is a terrible
decision and two it looks like this is
just a huge narrative right that yes
fighty was telling the truth when he
said we're no longer doing like these
big 10-year arcs but instead what we're
doing are getting like small arcs that
basically initiate paradigm shifts in
the marvel cinematic universe right so
like doctor strange deals with like the
complexities of the multiverse different
things like that but looking at
everything going on this idea of kang
and so on and so forth that technically
it looks like a three-part story arc at
least in terms of films but it's more
like five when you add the tv shows in
right so the multiversal collapse starts
in loki it continues on in spider-man no
way home it goes into doctor strange 2
it goes into ant-man 3 quantum mania
possibly potentially concludes in loki
season 2 although i have a hard time
believing that a villain like kang would
basically be defeated in like
quantomania or loki neither one of those
movies strike me as a movie that would
conclude the narrative or the story arc
of a character like king if anything i
could see them temporarily defeating him
and then him coming to the realization
or really the superheroes come into the
realization they can't necessarily
defeat king and if they really want to
expand on what king's capable of then in
turn he starts messing with the
multiverse in both time and space what
does that mean it means you would get
teams of people right whole groups of
superheroes that would show up in what's
basically a secret wars event where
they're pitted against each other by
kang lest they be destroyed and while
all that's going on they're trying to
secretly find a way to defeat kang but
they all basically face each other but
they're characters that we know from
different points in time right so that's
a way to introduce the x-men i mean in
that interview the fight he did he was
like no i mean the the whole idea of the
fox acquisition didn't really mess with
our plans to introduce the x-men and
then he went as far as to indicate that
the history of the x-men in the fox
films is actually in continuity that is
mcu canon the only way to make that work
is to take those characters from the fox
universe bring them into the marvel
cinematic universe their history intact
basically saying that like hugh jackman
wolverine all that stuff that he
experienced in the fox films that's all
his actual history he's just been moved
from his universe into our universe as
part of the mcu the same thing that
happened with venom all that kind of
cool stuff right so if that's the case
and that's what they're actually doing
kang would be the best way to do that
because all you do is you have this
situation where kang basically brings
together all these characters and makes
them fight and that would be awesome
because what it would mean is the mc you
can just kind of pick and choose who it
is they want right it's like a blackest
night brightest day kind of thing those
of you guys who never never read that
story which is an amazing story it was
over at dc comics it was part of green
lantern by the writer jeff johns
blackest night was basically a story
where you had the black lanterns and
they essentially resurrected everybody
every single superhero who ever died and
gave them a black lantern ring and then
they were basically lantern zombies
after that you go into brightest day and
basically dc went through and they chose
all the characters they wanted to keep
alive and then they gave them white
lantern rings which purified them and
then basically turned them back into
normal people everybody else just went
back to being dead right they was like
sorry about your luck guys you're dead
right here's that episode of the
twilight zone it's a wonderful life
right they just got shuffled off to the
cornfields by the little kid that was it
but it looks like that's what they could
do here right the kang basically brings
in the x-men and the fantastic four and
like avengers from different time
periods even members of the x-men and
the fantastic four from different time
periods right so looking at like the
x-men roster for example you would
basically get james mcavoy as professor
xavier michael fassbender as magneto but
then instead of like hugh jackman as a
young wolverine you get old man logan
and then instead of jean grey played by
sophie turner you get famke janssen jean
grey right the one from like the
original x-men movies then you get like
rebecca romain stamos mystique and then
you get like a younger version of
nightcrawler you get these kinds of
things right where you get these
different versions of the x-men from
different time periods and they kind of
have to figure out who the other person
is like holy cow you're me for the
future well you're me from the past that
kind of a thing right so like it would
kind of work all across the board the
same thing with a fantastic four now i'm
not saying those exact actors and those
exact roles would be picked but what it
would mean is that coming out of secret
wars that roster of x-men is the one
that we get that's the one that stays in
the marvel cinematic universe for
whatever reason now this is not a new
concept right it's actually teased to be
the post-credits scene for spider-man no
way home not the x-men and all that kind
of stuff but venom so i don't know if
you guys have heard the rumors or not
but what people are saying is that as
part of the post-credits scene for venom
that in the movie overall that tom hardy
will actually appear in the marvel
cinematic universe because he was yanked
into the mcu at the end of the venom
film at the end of no way home he'll end
up being shuffled back off to his
universe but a piece of the venom
symbiote will stay behind and that venom
symbiote will eventually going through
its own story arc and whatnot bond
itself to peter parker and that's how we
end up getting venom in the marvel
cinematic universe now i'm sure there's
probably going to be other story i'll
just play a role in there right the
introduction of eddie brock and
different things along those lines you
know tom holland having his own arc with
regards to venom and whatnot but that's
a rumor that's circulating around out
there do i know if it's true or not i
don't know but i think that kang the
conqueror is the way in which marvel is
going to introduce different characters
from across the multiverse into the
marvel cinematic universe and actually
keep them there because one thing to
understand about king this is one of the
things that makes him so significant
he's a multiversal guy right like
imagine you could get on a plane and fly
to any country in the world but imagine
you were doing that except instead of
countries it's whole universes that's
kang right just traveling around
alternate realities on a whim depending
on how he wants to do things and what it
is he's looking to achieve he can do
that in a variety of different ways
right enter and exit different universes
as he sees fit so being able to like go
to a universe where there's the entirety
of the x-men snatching them up and then
grabbing the avengers from different
periods of the marvel cinematic universe
and snatching them up and then he grabs
fantastic four from different periods of
time and snatches them up right and then
they all end up facing off against each
other in the secret wars event and then
maybe they end up officially defeating
kang at the end of that story and then
it's all like well i mean you know now
that we're here might as well hang out
right anybody want to do this movie's
equivalent of going and getting shawarma
like they did at the end of avengers
anybody want to do that you know and
then we watch how sales of whatever that
particular thing is skyrocket by like
300 percent like it did with shawarma
you guys remember that at the end of
avengers 1 like tony stark was like i
never had shawarma like we should go get
some shawarma and then like sales of
shawarma skyrocketed by 300 percent it
was crazy
it was hilarious to see that movie
having that kind of an impact but that
kind of a thing right kang i think is
one of these villains that it's not
going to be something like thanos with
the infinity stones and the snap or
whatever it's going to be on a much
grander scale and kang is going to be
the means by which they introduce these
other characters and teams from across
the multiverse into the marvel cinematic
universe so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section do
you think this is a good likelihood do
you think it's a bad likelihood what do
you guys think about all this let me
know but thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace